welcome back cardiac health is
especially important to remember during
the holidays when
we tend to eat and drink a little bit
more p3 healthcare partnered with prime
cardiology of nevada
to help spread awareness on cardiac care
and prevention
so we're talking about keeping up with
cardiac care for our seniors in our
local community
how are you guys doing that dr renee
i'll start with you
well you know holiday times are fun
times you know you're
you're meeting your relatives loved ones
especially
uh this holiday season is going to be
much different than the previous ones
people haven't met for a long time so
in any other holiday season but
especially this season
i expect that people will have much more
disruption
of their routine schedules uh you know
you're having so much fun you you kind
of forget to take your medications on
time
or worst case scenario you completely
forget to take medications at
all and those kind of things one has to
watch out um
have fun but be disciplined when it
takes
you know uh it takes some time but be
disciplined to
to make sure that you you stick to your
schedule for your medications for your
doctor visits
you're surrounded by good food you know
some amazing drinks and and family
members
and you know there's that tendency okay
well let me try a little bit let me do
this let me eat
with everyone else which is fine but
everyone has to keep in mind that you
know it's fine to eat
eat the nicer foods that are around but
also take a little bit of self-control
eat everything a little in moderation
instead of taking the second or third
helping
take one um maybe have one glass of wine
with the dinner instead of a few
and just be kind of cognizant about what
you're doing and what you're intaking
how can viewers actually prevent
these disruptions to their cardiac
health during this time watching how
much salt intake you have
especially for diabetics watching the
sugars and the sweet foods
and being okay eating it but just
controlling the amount that you're
eating
people with you know high blood pressure
or even congestive heart failure have to
really watch how much fluid and how much
salt they're taking
so just kind of being mindful that will
help prevent problems the next day or
down the road where
um okay now now we're having issues
one of the things that triggers a lot of
things
that are related to my field the
electrophysiology
or the rhythm problems is stress and
that stress can be physical stress
in a lack of sleep and those kind of
things or
emotional stress could be excessive
happiness or
excessive you know on the on the other
extreme
so what kind of treatments are out there
um for these long-term effects
uh well in terms of cardiology you know
we're especially nowadays cardiology
probably out of most medical fields it
makes
continuously making very advanced uh
new findings and we're being really
aggressive about treating people with
high blood pressure diabetes cholesterol
with medications
we have new therapies that are available
as well and we like to be aggressive and
kind of preemptive and preventative in
terms of so that they don't
run into problems you know in the next
day or weeks or a couple months after
all these holiday
times definitely something you want to
keep in mind for the holidays
and beyond call or text the number right
there on your screen or visit
primecardiology.com we'll be right back